I want to show you two sequences that if
you're only given a few terms
they are really hard. They both appeared
in Eureka, in this magazine, in their
puzzle section.
The first one I can do without
cheating and it goes like this:
3, 4, 6, 8,
nine, ten - no - eleven, no, twelve?
Yeah 12. Thirteen?
Fourteen - I've already given
you more than
the Eureka puzzle gave you. So what's the
formula?
There's a very simple formula but you
really won't guess it.
It's really annoying, you can see
why I hate these puzzles,
if they only give you a few terms. Let's
subtract 1 and we get
2, 3, 5, 7,
11, 13 - the primes.
So this sequence: it goes up by one, then
it goes up by two, and two, and four
oh and then two and so on - it looks like
it's something to do with adding twos
but in fact subtract one and it becomes
transparent. This is the kind of thing
where even if you say 'yes, all right,
there are mil-
but there are a million ways to extend
the sequence to explain the sequence'
but when you see the the answer, the the-
this is a good puzzle
in the sense that it's puzzling and yet
when you see the answer
you say all right yes I admit
that's what the answer has to be.
(Brady: So these were the
the primes plus 1 basically?)
Yes that's all.
(Okay, I'm going to come up with my own)
(sequence and just make it the primes)
(plus 8 or something and-)
Yeah you could certainly, just as hard -
harder, because it probably isn't in the
OEIS.
There's a related one and now I can do
it without cheating, it goes like this:
5, 8,
12 ,18, 24.
Now you look at that and you say, well
look, we've got 6 times 2, 6 times 3,
6 times 4,
and then there are a couple of
experimental errors at the beginning.
Basically this is going to be multiples
of six right?
Wrong! You want a chance
to think about it?
(All right, back in the room)
- Back in the room
here's the answer. Let me change these
commas to pluses:
2 plus 3, 3 plus 5,
5 plus 7, 7 plus 11 - it's
the sums
of two consecutive primes. Isn't that
annoying?
And yet when you see it it's clearly the
right answer.
So when you're given one of these
puzzles
on a quiz or an IQ test or a job
interview or something
the first thing you should do is excuse
yourself.
Go to the bathroom and look it up in the
OEIS.
Do you want to learn more about primes,
or maybe just numbers in general?
Well today's episode sponsor is
Brilliant: a resource
jam packed with quizzes, puzzles, and
courses that are not only
fun but designed to make you that little
bit smarter.
I particularly enjoy doing these daily
challenges,
they always make me smile. But the
courses like these,
they're the main meals on Brilliant.
You're always going to find something
appealing across a full range of
mathematics and science.
If you're already using Brilliant you
can also consider maybe
giving it as a gift. To learn more, give
it a try,
go to brilliant.org/numberphile - the
address there on the screen.
Using that /numberphile has the
bonus effect of giving you a 20%
discount on a premium subscription.
...16 steps. It must- it gets stuck,
it cannot move. Every square of- every one
of the eight squares around it that it
could move to,
it's already been to. So it die- the
sequence dies.